hey guys it's november 4th and the
weekend is finally here I'm chasity and
I've got your top five stories of the
week first up a new teaser video at Mass
Effect Andromeda gave us some hints at
the story on Tuesday Bioware released a
new teaser video for Mass Effect
Andromeda their highly anticipated
sci-fi role-playing game a narrator
invites the viewer to join the Andromeda
initiative a group that will travel
outside of the Milky Way galaxy in quote
a future that begins six hundred years
from where we stand in a time and a
place among unknown stars and unseen
dangers more information about the
Andromeda initiative will be announced
on november seventh AKA and seven day
after a delay the game is expected to
release in early 2017 next EA suggested
that star wars battlefront 2 is coming
out in fall 2017 during an earnings call
on Tuesday EA CFO Blake Jorgensen
strongly suggested that battlefront 2
will come out in fall of next year he
said it's coming a year from now
according to polygon he added were
working very hard on making sure that is
an extremely deep and engaging offering
during a previous called Jorgensen said
the game will have bigger and better
world he added that it will make use of
content from the new movies though he
didn't name any outright dice is
developing star wars battlefront 2
alongside another EA developer mode of
studios next EA also responded to
criticism of titanfall 2 releasing so
closely to Battlefield one titanfall 2
released on october twenty eighth and
received much praise from critics
despite the glowing reviews analysts
believe the shooter sales will be
substantially disappointing because of
it releasing a week after battlefield
one and a week before call of duty
infinite warfare and Tuesday's earnings
call EA CEO Andrew Wilson was asked if
he'd do things differently in the future
and refrain from leasing future shooters
so closely together Wilson said that
while battlefield one and titanfall to
have some overlap they fulfill very
different motivations in what a player
is looking for quote we think there's
really three types of players Wilson
said people that really love battlefield
and that kind of big strategic gameplay
that will orient in that direct
Shin the player that loves the fast
fluid kinetic gameplay of titanfall 2
that really Orient in that direction and
the player that just has to play the two
greatest shooters this year and we'll
buy both and again we're very very
excited about the quality in both titles
he continued we believe they both will
have a long sale cycle both this quarter
through the festive season and deep into
the years to come and so we think about
the long game on this we couldn't be in
a better position for what we think is
delivering great games to a very very
big player base next Nintendo hinted at
the price and launch lineup for the
Nintendo switch during an earnings
briefing nintendo president tatsumi
kimishima said the switch will be priced
in line with what you'd expect from a
nintendo console in the past the we
started at two hundred and fifty dollars
while the wii u debuted at three hundred
dollars however the switch is a console
mobile hybrid so it might be harder to
compare the only confirmed game for the
switch is the legend of zelda breath of
the wild as for third-party support you
can expect Ubisoft's just dance 2017
other developers like Activision EA
Warner Brothers Square Enix Konami and
Capcom have signed up to support the
console as well Nintendo will officially
announce the switches price launch
lineup in specs on January 12 during an
online presentation and at number 1
blizzcon 26 teams major announcements
over watches sombra was finally revealed
and diablo 3 is getting a new class
blizzard finally confirmed the hacker
centric overwatch character sombra today
during blizzcon opening ceremony the
company began to roll a video recapping
the launch of over watch the video
seemingly began to have technical issues
only for it to serve as an introduction
to sombra he thought this was supposed
to be the most advanced security system
on the planet we saw a short film
featuring her Widowmaker and Reaper
infiltrating some kind of top-secret
facility the video shows her going
invisible hacking things and teleporting
Blizzard CEO Mike Moore Han described
her as a stealthy offensive character
who is able to hack enemy abilities
sombras page on the overwatch website is
live detailing her abilities and weapon
she has a short-range machine pistol her
abilities are a lot like what seen in
the trailer hack can be used on enemies
to stop them from using abilities or on
health packs to make them unusable by
these thermoptic camelot's her go
invisible gaining movement speed this
effect ends by attacking using abilities
or taking damage translocator tosses out
a beacon that she can teleport to even
while it's still moving finally her
ultimate ability EMP lets out a blast
around her destroying barriers and
shields and hacking nearby enemies there
are also new maps on the way including
Oasis there's also a new mode called
arcade on the way that will host new
game modes new rule sets and exclusive
maps one of these maps is echo point at
arctica it's designed for arcades 1v1
and 3v3 arena game modes which are just
two of the modes coming sombra the
arcade and echo point antarctica will
arrive on the public test realm next
week with oasis coming to PTR in
December at blizzcon is opening ceremony
we also got an announcement that the
necromancer class is coming to Diablo 3
next year lizards Fred Pierce said that
Diablo 3's version of necromancer will
be inspired by the beloved class from
Diablo 2 he also referred to the
necromancer as a master of the dark arts
and a badass battlefield general overall
it's a character class that takes
advantage of everything Diablo has to
offer Pierce said Diablo 3's necromancer
class will go on sale in a character
pack in 2017 alongside other great
features beware
and those are your top five stories of
the week let me know what you think in
the comments below and don't forget
we're only one week away from extra life
it's our big charity event will be
streaming for 72 hours in three
different continents will be streaming
games the whole time and raising money
for the kids so check it out next week
and I'll see you next week